good day and welcome to nature's returns
a webinar speaker series hosted by the
gale centre for business and the
environment my name is Andrew and I will
be your host for today's webinar titled
mainstreaming natural capital into
decision-making frontiers and research
and policy the Yale Center or business
and the environment is pleased to
continue nature's returns a webinar
series that addresses the growing
importance of ecosystem service
valuation and investment each
presentation is recorded and available
on the Yale iTunes U channel we are
pleased to have professor Gretchen daily
here with us today Gretchen daily is the
Bing professor of environmental science
at Stanford University daily also serves
as faculty director of the natural
capital project an international
partnership whose goal is to enhance
social and environmental well-being by
mainstreaming the values of nature into
global resource decisions an ecologist
by training Daly's efforts spanned
fundamental research and policy and
business oriented demonstrations in over
30 nations her recent books include the
power of trees natural capital theory
and practice of mapping ecosystem
services and the new economy of nature
the quest to make conservation
profitable today Daly will present the
natural capital project and its
practical science-based approach towards
ecosystem service valuation aside from
highlighting the partnerships
overarching mission and the tools
developed to realize its vision
correction will also explore projects
where the natural capital projects work
has influenced decision-making around
the world before we begin the
presentation we would like to remind our
listeners that questions are welcomed
and will be directed to our speaker at
the conclusion of the talk you can type
questions directly into the gotomeeting
chat window and with that we welcome
Gretchen daily to nature's returns hi
everybody um thank you very much for
joining here I'm I'm actually over in
Stockholm just now so it's dark but it's
a great place
be for the innovation that's happening
in this row um I'm based at the royal
swedish academy of sciences for my first
ever leave from stanford and this is the
place where a lot of the foundation was
laid for integrating ecology and
economics and other realms of inquiry
and thought such as governance
resilience and other kind of big ideas
to provide the basis for creating really
actionable tools and approaches that
bring all these ideas into practice in
an effective way so anyhow it's a
pleasure to join I think Andrew and
Karina for inviting me and helping me
set everything up and i had thought i
was just going to be interacting with a
modest-sized classic yale and i didn't
realize there'd be quite a few people
joining from all over and from many very
experienced areas so I'm going to shift
a little bit what I was planning to
cover but what I'd love to do is open
enough time for a discussion i'll be
kind of watching this chat box as best i
can and if questions come up during i'll
see if i can address those and otherwise
i'll just end promptly by quarter of so
that we have a decent amount of time to
interact over like the frontiers here so
i'm also going to give a little bit of a
personal view there's so many ways to
get into these issues and i thought well
I might as well get into them in the way
I'm most experienced just for our
discussion and I'd love to hear from you
kind of from a personal perspective
where you're sitting in wrestling with
the challenges we all face weather here
on the webinar or afterward by email so
anyway thanks so let's dive in I guess
for me this goes way back but all I'll
start
maybe with my mentor how muni who was a
co-chair of the millennium ecosystem
assessment this big big process
involving thousands of scientists trying
to inform policymakers worldwide both in
private and public sectors of the
importance of ecosystems and that was an
unprecedented effort and kind of the
first ever to really assess natural
capital i'm going to use terms like that
and i know they're all it's all a matter
of debate and it would be best discussed
maybe over a beer which exact terms to
use but we were trying to come together
with the economics community at the time
and the I you know we know a lot about
other kinds of capital and over actually
thousands of years have developed
institutions for thinking about and more
formally trying to safeguard other types
of capital such as built capital or
infrastructure things like our homes and
automobiles or bicycles computers and so
on um human capital our knowledge and
skills and health financial capital and
social capital yet looking at this slide
here in the opening we knew next to
nothing we're really at the infancy of
in human history of considering natural
capital at least at that kind of the
global interconnected scale that demands
our attention today so ten years ago we
founded the natural capital project to
start trying to accelerate the rate of
innovation and inquiry and uptake of
kind of new understanding about the
values of the ecosystem you see in the
background so in the foreground we've
got a tea plantation in Uganda and
obviously no places managed perfectly I
am in the world but we know a lot about
the value of that plantation
from the perspective of the people
working in it the people packaging up
and marketing the tea and selling it all
over the world the government officials
trying to regulate what goes on in there
and so on yet we know next to nothing
about that cloud forest in the
background and what it means how much
it's worth in different dimensions to
people whose lives whether we think
consciously about it or not are
connected to that cloud forest so it was
from that kind of launching point 10
years ago that a few of us basically
some friends we've always called her
cell Xia amigos got together to try and
in span to achieve that acceleration but
also span the gulf between kind of
development of new knowledge and
actually adapting that knowledge and
taking it up in real decision making so
that friends were Taylor Ricketts who
have been a student with me and others
at Stanford and Peter Carr Eva Taylor
had just moved to World Wildlife Fund
and was heading up the big science shop
there and Peter kriva was at the Nature
Conservancy where I was just joining a
board and it was really exciting as a
moment to begin trying to stand this
gulf between sort of theory and practice
so in thinking strategically about what
to do we came up with these four main
objectives and pretty soon we realized
we desperately needed the expertise of
people at University of Minnesota and
those at the time were Steve Pulaski
who's still deeply involved and John
Foley who since moved on but formed a
core part of this core team of what is
really a global partnership with efforts
that moving into practice these
different kind of realms one through
four here number one co developing new
knowledge number two code
developing in both cases with users
really practical actionable tools for
bringing the knowledge into real-world
decision making and then taking the leap
and actually implementing these
approaches and tools in decision-making
and finally in selecting our engagements
throughout we've been really focused on
opportunity to scale up so there's a big
open question here maybe I'll flag a few
questions as we go on and would love to
hear your perspective on them but you
know how much can we expect to be able
to take models of success and replicate
and scale them that's I think an
outstanding question but it's something
we're driving toward hopefully in a
sensible way knowing that every place is
different but at the same time if we can
develop some standardized approaches
that seemed to work well under a lot of
conditions we can achieve that
transformation to more sustainable
living that we're all reaching for a lot
more quickly so these are the frontiers
and I'm going to dive in and just tell
kind of basically a story about each and
then you know open up for discussion but
on the general kind of conceptual front
this will be my only real conceptual
slide you know what we want to do is
change the way people think about
auctions identifying alternatives at the
top and yellow and then this diagram
that shows obviously you could put
arrows in in any direction and across
any of the little ovals but the idea
here was to see if we could develop
tools and approaches that would
illuminate how the different
alternatives would affect ecosystems how
those impacts on ecosystem condition and
like processes would translate into
changes in this delivery of services and
then this is a tough one how would
change in provision of different
services translate into human well-being
and then of course we want to work
through institutions sort of
transmitting this understanding and
information in a way that would motivate
veteran decision-making and enable
better decision-making so in the first
part of this with the little purple wavy
arrow we recognized that what the
millennium assessment had gone a long
way in showing just how much was known
you know about the status and trends of
ecosystems this form of living natural
capital and the provision of different
types of services but we also very
humbly also you know recognize how how
little we know we're really just sort of
chipping away at the tip of the iceberg
here when it comes to human dependence
and impacts on the natural world so a
key frontier that all of us I imagine
are focused on is just Co development of
knowledge that's relevant to some of the
big challenges around the world and when
I'm highlighting here on which my group
has focused for a couple of decades now
is just you know how would we how could
we harmonize agricultural production and
livelihoods with for example rain forest
protection and here's a shot of a little
bit of rain forest in the thick of
pasture and coffee production in a
southern part of costa rica that that is
one of my favorite haunts and you know
what are the values at stake here for
local people making a living on the land
over quite a few years and starting with
actually part of Taylor Ricketts
postdoctoral work we've tried to
quantify you know when are the inputs
from rainforest into agricultural
production and we started out looking at
pollination with
will be on the left to coffee those are
coffee blossoms you see there and then
move to looking at pest control there's
this devastating pest on coffee for
which the coffee berry borer wiping out
up to eighty percent of yield and places
it's moving around the world right now
where it's heavily infested and no real
effective control than any form like
chemical control so looking at natural
forms of pest control by birds and bats
and just to give you a taste of this so
Taylor ended up becoming quite famous
for finding first of all that even these
little bits of forest can confer a boost
in yield of twenty percent in nearby
areas like within a few hundred meters
maybe up to a kilometer from forest bees
aren't going to fly forever and they
also confer in this one study you know
fifty percent boost in quality so those
were a big deal where the margins the
profit margins are really slim and this
attracted quite a bit of attention it's
one farm but it was a new way of
thinking about nature in the midst of
farming activity and livelihoods then
recently Danny Carter who's now in
nature net fellow with the Nature
Conservancy he did this painstaking work
equally painstaking and I'm going to
tell you I guess how many bees first of
all are out in a typical coffee
plantation like this we found up you
know there are millions and millions of
individuals but over seven hundred
different species within just a month
sampling and I'm sure we didn't you know
find them all similarly with birds there
more than a 250 that are pretty commonly
out in these coffee plantations and
among the bats it's hard to catch them
all
a lot of them are really good at evading
us but there's at least about 70 out
there potentially suppressing insects so
with a lot of painstaking work we found
that birds suppress infestation by fifty
percent in this area shown with fats
that's a much more complicated story
where they eat both the beneficial
insects but also maybe help control some
of these pests and also the you know the
enemies of farmers that maybe you want
to get rid of so this just I'm giving
you to make a couple of points one is
that with you know there are painstaking
studies but pretty quickly we could open
up a new window into how nature in the
sea of farmland interacts with farmers
and livelihoods with real economic
values at stage and another thing we
found I guess is just to say that it's
humbling there's so many different types
of interactions out there and and again
we're just looking at the tip of the
iceberg and trying to understand how
pollination services for example are
provided across the world's agricultural
systems and the same with say natural
pest control services but what can we do
there's now been about you know some
thousands of studies over the past
decade with many many different research
groups applying many approaches to
understanding many different types of
ecosystem processes and services what
can we do to build on these individual
studies rather than saying okay we're
going to wait till we understand it all
to inform policy in a responsible way
what we wanted to do in addressing this
was just start building a new way of
thinking in the form of practical tools
that even with all the uncertainty that
we have in human independence and
impacts on nature with nonetheless
inform our decision
is better than flying blind so for this
part of kind of the aims in this
conceptual figure we're trying to link
ecosystems to human well-being that the
conditions and processes and ecosystems
their biodiversity and and other things
how do those generate services and
impact well human wellbeing so obviously
there's a whole range of things we could
consider here some would be relatively
concrete like food we know a lot about
it and we've gotten good over the past
10,000 years as a species at producing
it under all sorts of conditions and
then happiness which hopefully we're all
pretty JUnit but it's a much less
concrete thing and harder to know across
a society how to embed conditions for
happiness into policy but what we wanted
to do is start broadly and develop some
things that were really practical and
all kind of review where we are today so
we started out a few years back maybe
right at the beginning actually behind
the scenes developing models that start
if you look at the upper left corner of
the slide with basically land cover or
in marine systems you know what's going
on across a seascape and with that
relate land cover to provision of
different types of benefits like flood
control or carbon sequestration
agricultural production or biodiversity
as an attribute of the landscape and we
put this set of models that we are
starting to develop building on huge
amounts of work that have been done in
some of these fields especially in
hydrology and carbon dynamics
agriculture and integrate them into one
system invest for integrated valuation
of ecosystem services and and the many
trade-offs involved in say any landscape
or any few scape you're never going to
get it all so
the idea was to actually use this tool
in scenarios whether kind of at a huge
scale asking how ecosystem service
values would change with climate
disruption or shifts and the
distribution and numbers of people
urbanization especially or with new
types of policies and then getting right
down to business on on the ground asking
for example for this part of the Central
Valley in California where most you know
native habitat disappeared a long time
ago how would restoration of this
riparian area affect agricultural income
drinking water quality carbon
sequestration and so on similarly in a
coastal area how would restoration of
seagrass beds say influence nursery
habitats and thereby fishing income
erosion and flooding and risks
associated with that and Recreation
biodiversity so that not with the
contexts and together with some hundreds
of scientists from all over the world
starting out at NCS where peter triva
had really good connections we we just
got to work mostly in simplifying models
some of our models are new like him I'm
trying to even think I guess kind of
some of the crop pollination modeling
was new but a lot of these models we
took from existing much more complex and
very data intensive fields you know
remodeling that had been developed in
specialized fields and we tried to make
the models more accessible without
making them just completely inaccurate
and worthless but we wanted the whole
goal here was to be able to inform
conservation efforts worldwide you know
so we're linked up tightly with TNC and
WWF and we needed to be able to use data
that are available worldwide and work
with decision-makers and capacity that
exists worldwide
to start integrating this thinking into
decision-making so this is kind of the
suite of models with the more
terrestrial models and green the more
aquatic ones over and blue and then a
bunch that apply to both and I'll just
give you a taste of how they work in a
minute here but the idea also was to
link ecosystem change not only when we
talk about valuation not only to impact
in monetary metrics but looking at a lot
of different metrics we haven't gotten
that far in this yet although they're a
lot of really nice frontiers opening up
but at one level we were kind of this is
another thing good to talk over I'm
actually not that into beer but so to
speak over beer um you know how do we
describe the link between ecosystem
change changes and services and human
well-being there are a lot of different
ways we want to be able to understand
the links and it was kind of to our
relief that the decision makers with
whom we started working actually didn't
want us to convert everything into a
monetary say a dollar metric so let me
dive in and explain what we actually did
and i'm going to give you before i do
that sorry i have a terrific student
greg bratman working on the mental
health dimension of this and i just want
to take a tiny aside here because i was
just so surprised to see what this field
is doing so i've gotten into it only a
little bit through greg bratman and
james gross and others advising him but
there's much more going on there than i
had appreciated before so let's dive in
just quickly we all know that we're
urbanizing um you know in this just
unprecedented situation worldwide with
over half of humanity in cities today
and up to seventy seventy-five percent
expected to be in cities by 2050 and
city
living it's also very well documented
that while there are many benefits
associated with city living there's also
some real health risks one of them is an
increase in anxiety disorders of twenty
percent over living in rural areas and a
forty percent increase in mood disorders
especially related to depression and why
is that it turns out there actually a
lot of people this was reported in The
Economist in the summer in them 2011 and
through a nature article that if you're
into this I highly recommend by a German
group leader bogan and one of the main
people is andreas Meyer Lindenberg
who've written a lot about this and done
a lot of experiments and they discovered
using these new brain imaging approaches
that you can actually pretty much tell
where someone was raised between the
ages of zero and five and where they
live today on the basis of their stress
response the brain in the area that kind
of gets cemented in so to speak when
you're a real youngster is much more
active among urban people when they're
stressed than it is among rural people
people raised in rural areas when they
were between the ages of zero and five
and then similarly in the part of the
brain that remains so to speak more
flexible today the amygdala people
respond there's much more blood flow
sort of highlighted here to that region
when stressed in one of these machines
if you're currently living in a city
than if you're from a more rural area
that's just one dimension of a huge body
of work here I'm going to show another
dimension that that Greg Bratton's
developing and then this here the
pictures just show the Stanford campus
with this little nice hybrid shuttle bus
that takes unsuspecting volunteers who
think they're taking a walk and just
taking a bunch of pictures that's what
they're instructed to do it's like a 45
minute walk in either this pretty nice
looking oak woodland grassland area
shown on the right that's one of the
pictures taken by a subject or down on
el camino if you know the campus at all
in the bottom of photo it's kind of an
eight-lane four lanes each side some
places five lanes very busy thoroughfare
both are about you know 10 to 15 minute
drive from the campus and it's amazing
what that 45-minute walk will do to you
if you measure people's cognitive
performance before and after the walk as
well as aspects of their mood you get
striking results and this is new and
it's not formatted perfectly for here I
just threw it in but hope you will
forgive me the preliminary results
actually it's just gotten into press I
should take away preliminary but that
happened a week ago if you look at
working memory how well you can recall
weird things that psychology experiments
make you remember anxiety rumination
which is the tendency to sort of how
these terrible negative thoughts about
all the idiotic things you've done in
life and then kind of connection to
nature which is how much are you just
obsessing about yourself and all your
your hangups and mistakes versus feeling
kind of connected to the broader
biosphere you get a striking difference
just compare the bars urban and brown
nature and green in each graph I'm not
going to go through it in detail but
working memory improves your anxiety or
stress gets down and your rumination
goes down and your connectedness to
nature goes up if you've been lucky
enough to get assigned to the 45 minute
nature walk so this sort of thing
there's actually a lot of work in this
area maybe some of you know much more
about it and we're trying to figure out
you know how to bring this into urban
planning and there are a lot of cities
interested in doing so and starting to
do so and into thinking about child
development and things but
taking these different areas in
recognizing that we know some pretty
darned well and others were just kind of
opening up as new knowledge frontiers
we've created a suite of models that are
free and downloadable here at this
website and described in a pretty
theoretical form here in this book and
then by the way for any of the students
I have some extra copies still and I'd
be happy to send some if you email me
but going from there you know the big
challenges okay so we've got these tools
that help how are a bunch of computer
tools going to save the world you can
easily get cynical about that you know a
bunch of people partly based in Silicon
Valley overrating the potential for you
know software based approaches to do
anything so let's just dive into this I
I worry a lot about you know what our
best pathways to impact are so to speak
in in trying to drive change here so how
far have we gotten in implementing well
first I'm going to tell you about you
moving from this understanding through
institutions to identifying a bunch of
alternatives and actually informing
decisions in one of our very first sort
of demonstrations and that was in Hawaii
and I want to get a few things across
here and one is oh sorry I forgot about
this slide those of you that this is a
suite of sites in which we work today
just to give you a taste of it but like
i said i want to focus initially on
hawaii and then we'll turn the latin
america and china and one of the key
points is just that in all of the places
says i might be experiencing network
difficulties so hopefully someone will
interrupt me here as if things are going
south but i'll continue and less
interrupted so in hawaii em and in all
these places we've had three criteria
for engaging
number one was just that we were invited
into some kind of policy window of
opportunity to inform a decision so that
that was nice and it was basically
relatively easy through our wonderful
partnerships with the Nature Conservancy
and World Wildlife Fund with people
situated in offices all over the world
and working out in the context of land
use marine system management and
everything we had a lot of great
opportunities but one of the first that
came along was with I'll just dive into
it now with Kamehameha Schools this was
right at the beginning and it the head
of Kamehameha Schools land assets
division Neil hannahs happened to get
his degree at Stanford and had close
connections and a lot of trust and
brought us basically a policy window of
opportunity the second and third
criteria for engaging in places were
strength and commitment basically among
necessary partners hard to judge that
always but we were trying to be really
an inclusive strategically inclusive in
all of these engagements and then third
that I mentioned this earlier that there
was some potential for replicating and
scaling any approach we you know might
hope to be successful with so here in
Hawaii many people don't know kamehameha
schools but it's the biggest private
trust in the United States it was born
out of a terrible history at the end of
the monarchy when Westerners were
pouring in from Europe and North America
pushing Native Hawaiians off the land
over ninety percent it's estimated of
Native Hawaiians perished during this
period in the mid eighteen hundreds late
well late 1800s and into the 20th
century and the last princess in the
camejo kamehameha line princess Paula
hey Bishop actually inherited the land
shown in blue
if you've been to Hawaii you'll know
that you'll recognize that this is some
of the you know best land most prime
land in across the islands and she
inherited it from her many relatives who
were perishing of disease during that
time and interestingly she was married
to an educator and decided this is
boiling a complex story down a few
sentences but decided to create a trust
so that her legacy would be trying to
rebuild Hawaiian culture and build
capacity and hope among Hawaiian people
to live in what back then was becoming a
very globalized world all of a sudden so
she set up this trust and the trust for
over a hundred years managed assets in a
way illustrated by this slide showing by
keke you know developing some of that
prime land in ways that actually didn't
it conferred a lot of kind of standard
straight economic value commercial real
estate value and such but wiped out most
of the cultural natural and other values
that Native Hawaiians had held really
dear so again boiling the story down far
too quickly there was a lot of
resistance to this among the Native
Hawaiian community and finally around
the year 2000 the board of Kamehameha
Schools was was sacked and a new board
came in saying okay we're going to
launch a new approach trying to balance
economic value you know obviously we
have to measure it in some ways and
their lawyers in Chicago in LA breathing
down our necks to make sure that we meet
the fiduciary responsibilities of the
trust but we want to integrate
environmental dimensions of value
cultural dimensions of value educational
and community dimensions they became
very formal in defining these different
dimensions in measurable ways that I
don't have time to get into here but I
be happy to follow up with and when we
got together it was a matter of what to
do with this incredible land holding on
the North Shore of Oahu I'm going to go
back that that bit circled in red right
there so about 10,000 hectares of land
some of the last undeveloped farmland in
Hawaii and there's a huge food security
issue there with just a few days food
supply on the island really at any one
time some of the last undeveloped
coastline on Oahu and other incredible
cultural assets of space seek so after
working for basically a couple of years
in a very iterative process with with
different key local stakeholders three
main scenarios emerged as desirable for
evaluating for kind of the future of
this land developing housing to address
the huge inequities in housing and other
aspects of well-being among Native
Hawaiians and the many people who have
moved in from elsewhere develop
addressing sort of the energy security
issues which are huge and growing a
biomass feedstock there's a lot of
experience in their sugarcane likely and
third addressing the food security
issues and growing local food and
there's also forestry involved with here
so here's how the process worked of just
using invest models in the context of
this charged and you know historically
very um I don't know the right words to
capture this really briefly but yeah
there are a lot of issues going on here
and it wasn't just going to be a matter
of the investment in this context
getting know people working in a process
we evaluated across the 10,000 hectares
what would the landscape look like we're
it dedicated mostly to sugar production
with forest
and native biodiversity still in the
lower right corner and the upper reaches
of the watershed still in forest looking
at the residential development and then
finally at food crops for local markets
and reforestation of a native tree khoa
which is very highly valued humming
cultural and economic terms and what you
can see the invest outputs this is just
to give you a taste again show the
different whether you're going to get an
increase or a decrease over this 20 year
planning horizon across we only had
three services that we were modeling
back then here's what the it's easier to
see it all on this display with arrows
what the relative merits were of the
different approaches and all had an
expected you know positive return to
income and by the way this was led by
Josh Goldstein a postdoc then he's now
at the Nature Conservancy but overall
the better balance given the new
approach was to be attained through
agriculture and forestry and so
Kamehameha Schools actually committed to
investing over the long term and
diversifying agriculture and forestry to
achieve this balance I'm sorry to jump
ahead I'm going to speed up a little bit
and with that I just want to touch on
another key part to this and then I'll
be much quicker in the next examples but
there are other frontiers here and one
has to do with integrating different
kind of ways of knowing things through
the natural social and social sciences
and in the humanities you know
concerning how things work what's
possible and what really matters and
what is fair and how could we shift the
way things are done today the social
ecological system the people and and the
ecosystems and how obviously been
tightly interlinked over years and years
and to think about that getting into
what are the meanings and values today
for local residents so another leader in
this effort Rachelle ghoul hold together
with all of our Hawaiian partners posed
this bigger question you know how could
we elicit and shift values in a way that
informs decision-making to achieve that
more desired balance there are a couple
of papers just out on this I just kind
of wanted to flag them and flag one tiny
piece of the analysis that resulted from
a lot of work here that concerns how
ecosystems are used and identity or self
sense of self and here just taking
quotes from the many interviews that
were conducted you can see in the case
of this Hawaiian man in his 50s my
identity and the ecosystem are kind of
one in the same for me anyway the
ecosystem is what has made my identity
its what has made me who I am another
Hawaiian man quoted as saying you know
Hawaiians without land cannot be
Hawaiians these are pretty powerful
perspectives of identity and the
ecosystem and here a Japanese man
lifelong resident of Hawaii reporting
something similar that you know the
ability to farm or fish or to gather to
make food together to hunt it's hard to
explain who you are but it's the
practices that go with it the
interaction with family observing a
place and weather and times to go
hunting in to go fishing and I read
these out just because I wanted to
highlight frontiers and this is a really
key knowledge frontier and then
contrasting with a white man who's a
resident of for five years now in Hawaii
saying well I don't really feel that
identity is necessarily tied too much to
places so one level you know we're
talking about these software based
models for projecting changes in
services and human well-being and
level there these other approaches that
I feel anyway need to be developed
further and to bring more of this to
light since ultimately the way we
participate in a decision making process
and the way we engage or hope to give
voice to our values is pretty tightly
linked to how we think of ourselves so I
just wanted to touch on this and this
came into the Hawaiian context really
strongly but these three contrasting
sort of perspectives so anyhow they've
moved ahead with this really inspiring
plan I won't detail all of it it
involves wind energy on top of the other
things I mentioned and they want a major
award for it from the american planning
association in 2013 but what I'd like to
do is though it was an early case and I
just wanted to give you a deeper sense
of how that flowed but now raise this
complex question of whether we can
replicate and scale any anything we
declare as a model of success of process
and a set of actionable tools and things
so I'm going to dive into this with two
examples from Latin America and China
and the Latin America case concerns
water security above all else and just
to go through it a bit more quickly it's
about shining a light on the connections
between how upstream landholders deliver
or influence the deliria should say of
water downstream the quantity of water
the quality of water and the timing of
flow in particular whether there's
flooding or whether there's dry season
you know complete loss of flow or low
flow depends critically on how upstream
areas are managed so shining a light on
that and then relating the connections
to the many downstream consumers or
beneficiaries of you know this provision
of water related benefits
Sen and this is all in partnership with
the Nature Conservancy in the
inter-american Development Bank among
other partners the idea here is just to
figure out the science piece the
biophysical piece is to figure out what
sorts of investments you know targeted
where in the watershed what kinds of
activities whether in the top left
protecting existing native habitats
there it's forest replanting native
habitat or just introducing bitter
management practices in agricultural
systems what would achieve improvements
in water security for millions of people
living downstream of these huge upstream
areas across Latin America so a really
big question that pervades not only
Latin America but the world but with a
lot of leadership and up in Latin
America there's been development of a
pretty standardized approach now taking
in these biophysical data with
stakeholder preferences identifying on
the map in this blob that's a watershed
where there's high probability of being
able to engage local farmers and
ranchers in in a change in how land is
managed and where it's not a good idea
to go and ranking different activities
like fencing or conservation or these
best management practices reforestation
together with costs what would it cost
to those where dollars do come in you
know somebody's making an investment
here how do you get the highest return
on that investment so you're not valuing
water really as a an input to human
well-being you're just asking well what
would it cost to implement different
strategies across the landscape to
improve access to high quality abundant
water then you get an investment
portfolio of where you could target
those dollars to achieve an improvement
and how and this approach we've now
tried to tailor
are in the invest models in a somewhat
different tool in this family of tools
called yolks that brings in the eco
hydrology together with some of the sort
of the economics and then working with
the inter-american development bank and
a suite of other partners through the
Nature Conservancy the financing the
governance of these water funds and
monitoring of a bunch of them over the
long term that's just initiating now and
and it's amazing over the past few years
starting in Ecuador really and then
Colombia we're now seeing scaling up to
over 40 funds across Latin America today
and also some testing in three places in
east africa and and actually some action
in the united states and canada so
that's a sum of an approach that has a
lot of potential and looks exciting and
same in china and i'm sorry i'm going on
i'm going to summarize china all too
quickly but the the policy window in
china is just staggering to see today
the state council the president and
premier and main body governing the
country has declared China's dream as
becoming the ecological civilization of
the 21st century and everybody is well
aware of all the stuff we read in the
Western news about the you know dire
environmental problems in China and in
fact so aware that decision makers are
saying okay will you tell us scientists
where and what should we protect in
order to harmonize people in nature and
China actually launched one of the first
and by far the biggest by far and away
the biggest payment for ecosystem
service program in the world and you can
see on the map here there's a hundred
and twenty million households that were
enrolled this was after massive flooding
along the Yangtze River primarily
and this grain degreeing program and the
natural forest conservation program in
the dark green basically get payments as
part of a wealth transfer program you
could think of it from the eastern
provinces to the Western inner parts of
the country in the northern part of the
country and today just in the past few
years a new approach has been launched
that involves zoning the entire country
using the investment and these
investments were really co-developed and
immensely improved with type
collaboration especially in hydrology in
other areas with scientists in China
we've seen policymakers zone the country
for at the national level it's owned at
each scale down to kind of the
provincial and County scale but for
these nationally critical ecosystem
services and we've been the natural
capital project asked to kind of
demonstrate well how would you put this
kind of understanding of which places
are most important for securing say
water resources or helping with air
quality and sandstorm control
interestingly biodiversity is weighted
equally among these top priority
services you know as a condition of
ecosystems across the country so we've
been given these three places very
high-profile policy context concerning
water supplied in the north of China and
then Hainan Island a real biodiversity
hotspot globally I mean in all cases the
model is to understand who are the
beneficiaries of services in the top
right and ensuring that they're
investing through you know in fund flow
in the livelihoods and activities and
well-being of providers of ecosystem
services in the top left and through
that investment that we're achieving
sustainable changes
livelihoods in activities and you could
say production and consumption and this
involves a lot of understanding all of
the work involves like I mentioned in
Hawaii a lot of social science frontiers
understanding how people are making a
living today and how these policies
would impact their livelihoods and
ensuring that dual goals are achieved of
poverty alleviation together with
securing natural capital and sort of
national security as people put it so
I'm actually not going to go through
this there's a nice paper in pnas led by
professor chinua at the Chinese Academy
of Sciences showing how this was
implemented to secure water the only
surface water source for Beijing Mearing
watershed just north of the city and you
can see it there I'll go over super
quickly basically increasing population
in Beijing going way up declining in
flow of water over the decades
increasing pollution from industry other
waste water and agriculture and then
looking at this framework figuring out
how to pay providers and these were rice
farmers as of a couple hundred years
when in one of the dynasties land-use
change dramatically in this area and
getting people to shift to dryland
agriculture or to other kinds of
livelihoods and basically there was a
massive change within a five-year period
and water yield has gone up total
nitrogen and total total phosphorus have
gone down and now they're really
fine-tuning this program expecting to
achieve even more of a sort of win-win
for livelihoods and water security but
the last thing I'll mention is just this
final sort of big advance being made in
China now is to actually forget about
trying to green GDP which has been this
multi-decade effort on the part of
many people worldwide that's politically
quite fraud and instead introduce a
separate metric metric called gross
ecosystem product that measures the
total value of ecosystem goods and
services supplied annually by an area it
could be a county or province or a
municipality or the whole country this
is to be reported alongside GDP to be
made very public to generate incentives
for achieving high gep and also pressure
to achieve that you know high gep and it
was approved about a year ago and now is
in rapid development so let me just
close now in saying that there are a lot
of frontiers here a lot of challenges
ahead and a lot of other efforts have
come up over the past 10 years that are
key to standardizing approaches making
the approaches a lot better tailored to
particular kinds of decisions in
businesses I didn't get into the
corporate engagements that we have with
coke and Dow and Unilever but we're
working closely with the natural capital
protocol that key effort led by the WB
CSD and others to provide guidance for
executives and other stakeholders and
focusing more effort on these key
decision context here that all in with
to advance on all of these frontiers and
develop next-generation sort of
demonstrations that go a lot further in
achieving the ultimate outcomes of
improving both livelihoods and securing
natural capital now I apologize I mean
to go on as long as I did but I'll stop
now and just thank you for your patience
and would really welcome any exchange we
can have now and then later I guess
over email or other ways thank you very
much thank you so much for your
presentation Gretchen we have time for
two questions from audience members that
we would appreciate your input on Andrew
asks when simplifying current
biophysical models how did the project
team decide how much simplification was
appropriate and how to quantify modeling
uncertainty for the invest tool thanks
Andrew you've asked a really key
question and I'll just give a brief
answer here first we decided to develop
three tiers of modeling of different
levels of complexity and with different
data requirements so we had a very
simple tier where you could just look at
sort of relative impacts of different
scenarios or choices on a landscape or
seascape and the provision of services
through to a much more complex tier
where you could actually use results
from a SWOT model or some other very
complex hydrology or other model in this
integrated framework and and then maybe
bring in a pollination model or
something like that so the idea was just
to achieve the integration and not fuss
too much over the right level of
complexity that's a big frontier for us
especially in hydrology since so many of
the users of the models are focused on
kind of water security and flood risk
and things like that so we are seeing a
lot more work in this area there's a
nice article by led by drugu slaw in I
think water policy research and it kind
of lays out some of these frontiers but
the key is next the big focus is to both
simplify so that say in hydrology you're
focusing on the output that a decision
maker most needs for in a particular
decision context rather than on the
entire set of hydrologic processes going
on in the system and the
second so that you are reporting
uncertainty in a way that's most useful
in that particular decision context so
we're really tailoring things and trying
to lose information that isn't so
critical to the particular decision at
hand but in deep and understanding and
illuminate what's going on in terms of
uncertainty and key aspects of
hydrologic processes like peak flow you
know and flood risk that kind of thing
or certain aspects are you going to hit
a minimum flow period of so many days
and the dry season that kind of thing so
that's a general answer but both of your
questions are spot-on in terms of
modeling frontiers great thank you
threaten the second question comes from
Nancy who asks you mentioned this toward
the end but how and where do you see
private enterprise and entrepreneurship
advancing the goals of the natural
capital project so we've seen interest
in a lot of different areas and I show
here actually some of the key areas so
in the context of water security there
are many many different types of firms
that are interested and we're working
with coca-cola and with Unilever partly
on number one as well as many you know
hydropower firms in the context of some
of the water fund work in Latin America
hydropower is one major consumer in the
context of those water funds and it's
usually private firms running businesses
in the context of commodity supply
chains and securing those supply chains
there's a huge amount of interest and
leadership in the context of
infrastructure design and investment
we've mostly been working there with the
Latin American Development Bank but
they're connected to many you know
private sector firms that
make these investments and that actually
implement them and then in the context
of coastal resilience and protection a
key interesting example as Dow Chemical
we're through the Nature Conservancy
again we've been engaged in looking at
their huge assets most of which sit
along coastlines for shipping purposes
and along you know at river mouths so
we've been working with Dow at looking
at the implications of alternative
citing choices for infrastructure in the
future and how to protect existing
infrastructure that by chance is subject
to in the Gulf of Mexico to really high
hurricane return frequencies and
similarly in in sustainable cities we
haven't yet I got number seven there is
corporate reporting we haven't yet
gotten into this as much as we would
eventually like it's just a trickier
area and I won't get into to why now
because we're short on time but it it's
a lot trickier to reveal what is going
on at a kind of sector-wide level
comparing corporations in their
dependence and impacts on different
natural capital assets but that that is
a really key frontier so there's also
maybe one last thing among industry
leaders a lot of movement toward better
practices and these roundtables on
commodities or work with the natural
capital coalition and the natural
capital declaration and protocols I am a
drive toward developing some standards
and understanding which kinds of tools
could be most useful in which kinds of
decision contexts and how to foster
development of those tools and
approaches in a way that's most
effective and accelerates uptake
so there has been a lot of opportunity
and interest and leadership and we're
really keen maybe a final thing here
actually developing a data analytics and
visualization platform with Microsoft
that will in our dream we're just
getting going on this make widely
available and freely available the core
basic data that you need to conduct
these sorts of analyses and visualize
the implications of alternative
decisions or choices in a platform that
we will make open to the global
community for you know featuring
different types of tools that eventually
will be highly interoperable and
featuring also kind of demonstrations of
how to achieve the change that we're all
reaching for so thanks for that question
then again i'm sorry i've gone on a bit
but thanks for your attention and i look
forward to being in touch with many of
you perfect Thank You Gretchen that
concludes the talk on mainstreaming
natural capital into decision-making
once again we would like to thank
Gretchen daily for joining us today if
you wish to review a recording of this
webinar please visit the gale centre for
business and the environment website or
access the recording through the Yale
iTunes University podcast thank you for
joining us until next time this is
andrew wu from the yale center for
business and the environment